an architect's design process always
starts on site the first thing we always
do is go on site explore the site and
understand all the parameters that are
going on around us what's going on guys
my name is David tomich I'm a registered
architect here in Western Australia and
today we're talking about the
architect's design process from start to
finish we're going to be looking at
everything that goes through my mind as
I'm designing and as I'm putting
together a package for a client so like
I mentioned the design process always
starts on site we go outside we
understand what the client is talking
about and we get a brief put together by
stepping foot physically on the site you
can understand the lay of the land you
can understand how the winds and the
cross breezes actually work on that site
and how the surrounds affect it so for
example if there is a house next door it
might be blocking those severe
southwesterly winds that could be coming
through on another hand there might be
this perfect little pocket of a corridor
that lets that breeze cut through that
entire site without stepping on the site
you actually have no idea go Google Maps
is phenomenal but it just doesn't give
you enough critical information
obviously you document and take as many
photos and videos as possible of the
site at the very start to make sure you
can refer back and refresh your memory
as you're designing and as the process
continues along something I find very
important very critical is to try find
key elements of that site so finding
unique characteristics either from the
Landscaping the environment the views or
potentially the surrounding neighborhood
taking a look at the characteristics of
the street and understanding if the
design will actually suit that
environment or if it would just be a
monolithic design that doesn't work at
all so everything from day one starts on
the site and is one of the most critical
times of the design throughout the
entire process once a site visit has
been completed then it's time to
actually start documenting designing and
thinking this process through it for me
personally every design starts with a
hand sketch now like you all know I
can't draw to save my life but it does
help me get my thoughts out from my
brain and on paper most of the time I'll
use more folio Trace get out a blank
base paper sketch out what the actual
site looks like massing out shapes and
areas it's basically blocking and
stacking in a floor plan point of view
to understand how that site plan work so
if it's an apartment building if it's a
house it's very important that we think
about the movement the traffic and the
flow of people throughout that
environment before we even start
thinking about the design itself we want
to make sure that that site is optimized
working properly and then we can further
break down the design so once I have a
good understanding of how that aside is
actually going to work where things sit
where the best optimized areas are for
each individual item then it's time to
actually break down very very quickly
all the planning regulations around that
site because every single site here in
Australia is different has a different
planning policy different regulation
different zoning this process has to be
done for every single property now again
it is one of the most critical elements
because if you miss something like the
council mandate it's two fully grown
trees in the front Verge that might
completely derail your entire design and
force you to go back and redesign as
much as possible at this point in time
it's important that we get the creative
mind working rather than the critical
analysis mind from that site plan that
we did previously to transition for me
personally from a critical to a creative
mind I try to take as much inspiration
as I can from different mediums so we
start looking at inspirational
Architects from around the world we
start looking at different design
mediums different design textures we
start breaking down material and color
palettes that work together in that
environment so from that site visit we
might be able to comprehend that the
best medium for this site is a
combination of earthy tones we might be
using a bit of rammed Earth a bit of
fiber cement cladding we might be using
some metal cladding I don't really know
what is happening in this design just
yet but I know that these textures these
materials are going to work with what's
on site and what the context and the
surrounds actually mean so by putting
together these materials and these color
palettes understanding some key
precedence and being inspired by some of
the architectural greats then we can
actually start putting together a design
typically for me this means all of the
massing has been completed in more folio
Trace I understand the general layout of
how the start of the house is going to
work and how the site is going to work I
then transition into archicad and I'll
start massing out full shapes and sizes
so I'll take the brief from the client
if they want four bedrooms five bedrooms
whatever it is start massing and placing
that out to work for that site as best
as possible personally I will always be
designing in both 2D and 3D I'm never
going to be designing just in a floor
plan just in section or just an
elevation the fact that architecture has
progressed so far from just a 2d manual
paper and Pen drawing and now that we
have a full 3d model at our disposal at
all times as we continuously draw allows
us basically to rapidly adjust that
design line to suit every single design
decision that we make along the way so
let's say all of a sudden we've had to
protrude one section of that house out
and normally you just think okay on to a
plan that doesn't have too much of an
impact but as soon as we look at that in
a three-day elevation point of view we
might understand there are so many more
flaws with that option that we've just
decided to make then we could see it
just on a floor plan so for me form will
always follow function but the form is
just as important sometimes as the
actual function so by designing in these
3D elements we're able to basically
create a beautiful 3D architectural
model from the outside and a fully
functional interior as well once this 3D
model is completed then it's more so
about documenting this journey and this
experience with the client the 3D model
means absolutely nothing until you can
map and model everything that needs to
be communicated as best as possible the
storytelling is just as important as the
actual design that's why I will go ahead
and document a lot of this project as
well as produce some 3D ended so this
story can be told we want people to be
excited about something that hasn't been
built yet we want them to be part of
this journey as much as possible don't
we start breaking down these key
elements that we've been able to pull
out from the site we talk about the
narrative as you approach we talk about
the materials and the textures and we
tell that entire story through 3D images
before we talk about 2D plans and
overall that is basically my creative
Journey from start to finish to get a
sketch design out for a client from
absolutely nothing it is all about
understanding the site understanding the
context then understanding your
fundamental principles your values and
your precedence and then moving on to a
designer and working in both 2D and 3D
simultaneously to produce the best form
follow functions architecture possible
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did make
sure you check out the playlist to the
side of me for more great architectural
content if you love the video make sure
you smash that subscribe button down
below but like like always I'll see you
next Monday